[Applauso]
questa è una storia vera
sono stato invitato qualche tempo fa a
partecipare ad un caffè letterario sulle
dolomiti un chirurgo invita ogni anno
una personalità di un certo settore
quell'anno si parlava di spazio sono
stato invitato io quell'anno era un anno
elettrizzante perché il nostro satellite
e mars express aveva trovato con un
radar italiano acquasumarte liquida
salata
ora acqua liquida salata su marte da un
punto di vista scientifico è una
scoperta epocale perché significa molto
probabilmente la presenza di vita su
marte
alla fine della serata io ero ancora
circondato da turisti che volevano
sapere delle nostre nuove missioni delle
nuove tecnologie e sono stato affrontato
da una persona che mi ha chiesto di
guardare a questa foto potete leggere
con voi
penso che sia del tutto superfluo che io
mi soffermi sulla tragicità
dell'immagine in se voglio leggere però
con voi
la frase a corredo l'umanità non ha i
soldi per estrarre l'acqua nelle zone
aride però ha i soldi per cercare
l'acqua su marte
la domanda è c'è vita intelligente sulla
terra ora questa è una situazione alla
quale chi fa il mio mestiere viene
esposto piuttosto di sovente quindi ho
deciso di rispondere e di farlo con la
pacatezza e la metodicità che la scienza
mi ha insegnato e voglio farlo con voi
oggi comincio con la missione forse era
più iconica di tutte le missioni di
esplorazione spaziale l'uomo sulla luna
questa missione ci ha detto noi possiamo
farlo non soltanto noi possiamo pensarlo
noi siamo l'unica specie di questo
pianeta ad aver fatto questo ad aver
lasciato il nostro pianeta e sarà andato
sul nostro satellite ed essere ritornati
l'unica specie ma in più questa missione
si è regalato molto di più
135 mila brevetti 135mila significa
nuovi prodotti nuove aziende nuovi posti
di lavoro significa progresso economico
oltre che scientifico significa
benessere però una potrebbe ancora
obiettare che non rispondiamo alla
domanda del bambino ma vediamole queste
tecnologie primo la tac
l'atac veniva utilizzata per cercare
difetti sulle strutture immateriali
delle navi di apollo oggi la tac la
troviamo in tutti gli ospedali del mondo
per fare diagnosi per guidare la
chirurgia i filtri per l'acqua che
utilizzavamo per depurare l'acqua degli
astronauti
oggi li usiamo in tutte le parti del
mondo dove l'acqua è carente per
permettere a quei bambini di bere da
pozzanghera altamente contaminate da
virus e da batteri perché ora le abbiamo
addirittura resi portatili il
microprocessore ora il processore
esisteva già chi fa il mio mestiere però
sa che chi cosa vola nello spazio deve
essere estremamente leggero ed
estremamente piccolo quindi il
processore ha dovuto necessariamente
diventare il microprocessore
ora ditemi oggi sulla terra una macchina
che non abbia un microprocessore a bordo
intendo tutto dall'automobile al vostro
telefonino agli strumenti medici agli
strumenti per cercare acqua tutto in più
una serie sterminata di prodotti tecnici
abbigliamento per il grande freddo il
grande caldo addirittura per le fiamme
tute ignifughe per i pompieri senza
amianto maschera portatili per
l'ossigeno coperte termiche oggi
tristemente indossate dai migranti cibo
liofilizzato il cibo liofilizzato che ha
perso l'acqua per essere trasportato
nello spazio si può trasportare molto
bene adesso in tutte le parti del mondo
grazie a questa tecnologia questo però
veniva 50 anni fa oggi che cosa facciamo
oggi la nostra priorità è la terra
viviamo un periodo di grandi cambiamenti
su scala globale
abbiamo un'opportunità però possiamo
osservarli comprenderli e di intervenire
per cambiarli ed è osservandoli dallo
spazio
ecco allora che abbiamo una serie di
missioni le sentinelle l'agenzia
spaziale europea che ci permettono di
fare proprio questo primo possiamo
capire quali sono gli elementi nocivi
nell'aria non soltanto possiamo capire
la quantità di anidride carbonica
l'anidride carbonica un effetto
secondario che è aumenta la temperatura
del pianeta
quindi misuriamo lo scioglimento dei
ghiacci il polo nord ha perso 10 taglio
di ghiaccio
come conseguenza misuriamo
l'innalzamento dell'acqua il 60 per
cento della popolazione mondiale vive
entro i 100 chilometri dalla costa
quindi un dato estremamente importante
in più facciamo qualcosa di ancora di
più non soltanto troviamo acqua per quel
bambino ma troviamo umidità quindi
troviamo potenzialità di trovare acqua
anche dove questo estremamente difficile
in più proprio perché abbiamo trovato
l'umidità possiamo possiamo permettere
una migliore agricoltura quindi non
soltanto diamo da bere quel bambino ma
gli diamo anche da mangiare
la cosa interessante di questo è che il
radar che oggi ci permette di trovare
acqua è lo stesso o meglio e
l'evoluzione della specie un radar ad
apertura sintetica e l'evoluzione della
specie del radar che ci ha permesso di
trovare l'acqua su marte nella sua
funzione di interferometria quello
stesso radar ci permette di misurare
movimenti millimetrici di tutte le
costruzioni che l'uomo ha sulla terra ad
esempio la sanità strutturale delle
scuole dei nostri figli
le dighe i ponti chi di voi ha un
cellulare
chi di voi a internet sul cellulare
chi di voi ha un gps sul cellulare tutte
queste ci siamo servizi che per voi sono
ovvi e scontati vi vengono forniti dallo
spazio vi vengono forniti dall'agenzia
spaziale europea ma l'osservazione della
terra dallo spazio ci ha permesso di
fare qualcos'altro ci ha permesso di
prendere coscienza di quanto la terra
sia fragile e si è esposto ad esempio a
questa minaccia
cinque estinzioni di massa tutte 5 ed è
l'opinione scientifica più comune sono
state generate dall'impatto con un
asteroide superiore al chilometro di
diametro
noi oggi non potremmo farci niente
nessuna agenzia spaziale al mondo può
farci niente
non voglio rovinarvi la domenica non vi
preoccupate lesa e la nasa lavora
proprio a questa missione la missione
d'arte era questo e di timo è uno
steroide di un chilometro di diametro
non vi preoccupate non sta venendo verso
la terra però è un ottimo oggetto di
test
vogliamo colpire con un dardo la sua
luna e cambiando la velocità della luna
deflettere mo
la traiettoria di didimo di 6.000 km la
terra 12.000 chilometri di dymo non ci
colpirà mai noi con il nostro ingegno
con la nostra competenza ci siamo
costruiti questa possibilità di
sopravvivenza
i dinosauri non sono stati capaci e
infatti si sono estinti però a noi
interessa l'uomo sullo spazio all uomo
nello spazio
e se nel 69 l'uomo nello spazio nella
missione della luna c'è stato per pochi
giorni
oggi noi abbiamo volato 90 equipaggi su
questo oggetto la stazione spaziale
internazionale
li abbiamo resi eterogenei quindi uomini
e donne e gli abbiamo allungato la
permanenza almeno sei mesi
questo ci ha permesso di scoprire
moltissimi aspetti prima di tutto che
l'uomo non è fatto per volare nello
spazio
abbiamo moltissimi problemi abbiamo
osteoporosi assottigliamento del muscolo
assottigliamento del sistema
cardiovascolare problemi con le
radiazioni ma non soltanto ci hanno
permesso
queste missioni di sapere questo ma ci
hanno permesso di sviluppare in medicine
per curare proprio questi aspetti e
queste stesse medicine ce le ritroviamo
poi sulla terra ma la stazione è stato
qualcosa di più è stato un esperimento
politico è stata realizzata da 5 paesi
europa stati uniti russia canada
giappone e ci ha dimostrato che lo
spazio è un'omissione talmente alta che
anche quei paesi che a quel tempo non
andavano d'accordo sulla terra si sono
messi d'accordo hanno fatto la pace per
realizzare una missione del genere
quindi se volete il problema dell'acqua
e del cibo è prima di tutto un problema
tecnico
bisogna trovarlo bisogna estrarla ma poi
è un problema di distribuzione
niente come la missione spaziale aiuta i
rapporti internazionali e quindi aiuta
la distribuzione ma in più
questa missione ci ha permesso di
trovare moltissime tecnologie per la
prima volta nella storia dell'uomo
abbiamo riparato il dna danneggiato da
radiazioni la stazione orbitante è un
sistema chiuso quindi l'acqua è
contenuta perciò forse adesso vi farò un
po fastidio quello che sto per dire ma
abbiamo dei sistemi di depurazione
dell'urina l'urina degli astronauti
viene ri bevuta il sudore degli
astronauti viene ricevuto tutte queste
tecnologie possono essere utilizzate
sulla terra dove l'acqua è carente
abbiamo sviluppato delle alghe che sono
altamente nutritivo e forniscono
alimenti dove il cibo è carente sulla
terra come ad esempio in centrafrica e
in sudamerica
guardate che cosa vuol dire fare un
massaggio cardiaco sulla stazione
come vedete una manovra estremamente
complessa ecco perché abbiamo
trasformato il defibrillatore che voi
trovate ovunque e lo abbiamo reso
portatile questo vi permette di trovarlo
dappertutto non soltanto nei centri
sportivi ma anche nelle strade nelle
piazze salva vite ma vogliamo fare di
più vogliamo fare questo vogliamo
mettere il defibrillatore su un drone
voi avete un art nel vostro telefonino
schiacciatela il drone arriva dove siete
voi ci arriva perché avete un segnale
gps che vi viene fornito da noi quindi
si arriva molto precisamente
[Applauso]
quel drone a terra vicino a voi parla i
passanti dice questa persona non si
sente bene mettimi sul suo petto al
resto penso io e salva vite vi presento
simon simon è il primo robot ad
intelligenza artificiale
lui ha un software di riconoscimento
facciale quindi non soltanto riconoscere
a faccia del comandante in questo caso
alexander gerst ma in più ne comprende
lo stato d'animo
quindi gli si rivolge con modi e toni
adeguati per quel suo particolare stato
d'animo
ora per missione a lungo termine questo
tra d'esempio andare su marte è una
tecnologia fondamentale perché ci
permette di alleviare il carico di
lavoro comprendere le dinamiche
dell'equipaggio riportato sulla terra a
molteplici utilizzi ad esempio nelle
missioni di esplorazione dei poli grande
isolamento
le navi che restano in mare per sei mesi
oppure le persone anziane non sarà mai
come un essere umano questo è chiaro ma
certo meglio di una macchina muta la
prestazione sia permesso anche di
cambiare un altro paradigma questo è il
futuro dell'aviazione queste skylon
skylon a un motore ibrido una parte
motore commerciale quello che usate
sugli aerei di oggi una parte un motore
razzo skylon arriva ad una certa quota
con il motore commerciale accende il
razzo esce vola 28.000 km orari vuol
dire new york sydney in tre ore
vuol dire che è tutta diciamo
l'inquinamento intanto avviene meno
perché è più corto e poi è fuori
dall'atmosfera quindi non inquiniamo la
terra ma noi vogliamo fare di più
vogliamo fare questo
questo è il cancello sul sullo spazio
profondo
è una nuova base una nuova stazione
orbitante questa volta attorno alla luna
non più attorno alla terra ci costerà
dieci volte meno della stazione spaziale
abbiamo imparato anche a ottimizzare i
nostri processi
in più ci permetterà di fare diverse
cose primo supportare alle missioni di
superficie secondo supportare alle
missioni che andranno su marte
superficie sulla luna pensate astronauti
a bordo nel 2024 prima donna sulla luna
nel 2024
in più ci permetterà di realizzare un
altro
un sogno che è quello di costruire una
base sulla luna perché questo quello che
vogliamo
vogliamo tornare sulla luna ma questa
volta non per rimanerci non per esserci
ma per rimanerci
la luna ricca di platino di titanio
celio tra che permette di produrre
energia nucleare senza scorie
radioattive è un'opportunità scientifica
unica anche perché permette di osservare
lo spazio senza l'aberrazione
dell'atmosfera quindi possiamo avere
radiotelescopi che non sono filtrati
dell'atmosfera ed è un opportunità di
testare tutte le tecnologie che
utilizzeremo poi nel volo ben più
complesso quello per marte però la luna
questa diciamo questa nuova sfida ci
permette anche di sviluppare tecnologie
primo costruire la base lunare non la
costruiremo come se fossimo sulla terra
utensili materiali pensate cosa vuol
dire costruire una casa sulla terra non
faremo così lanceremo tutti e quindi
lanciare poi tutto questo sulla luna non
così cambieremo completamente una
stampante 3d la polvere che è già sulla
luna e il sole come unica fonte di
energia e la base la costruiremo
completamente automaticamente ora
riportate questa tecnologia sulla terra
che cosa significa significa avere
possibilità di costruire case in
terremoti dopo i terremoti o dopo gli
tsunami in ambienti estremamente
difficili ma gli astronauti poi non
avranno soltanto bisogno della base
avranno bisogno anche di utensili
equipaggiamenti ora una parte di questi
utensili verranno lanciate altre
dovranno essere costruite lì quindi
avremo bisogno di plastica di metalli
ora qual è la fonte ovvia di plastica e
metallo sulla luna è quella che abbiamo
portato noi sono i lander i lander una
volta utilizza atterrati non servono più
quindi cannibalizzare mo tutta la
plastica e tutti i metalli e liri
stamperemo con stampanti 3d in oggetti
utili per quella fase di missione
il riciclo dovrà essere fondamentale
sulla terra se vogliamo preservarla
questo è il cratere shackleton al sud
della luna quello che vedete in rosso e
acqua
acqua vuol dire vita vuole dire acqua da
bere vuol dire ossigeno e idrogeno
ossigeno da respirare ossigeno e
idrogeno come combustibili per mantenere
la base però quell'acqua è prima di
tutto ghiacciata e secondo è mischiata
terriccio vuol dire che dobbiamo avere
delle tecnologie per estrarre l'acqua
queste stesse tecnologie saranno
utilissime per quel bambino tutto questo
stiamo già testando lo stiamo testando
qui nel ghiacciaio di zermatt 11
università europee tra le quali
politecnico stanno testando tutte queste
tecnologie nei ambiente rappresentativo
della luna in più abbiamo la robotica il
nostro comandante luca parmitano
controllerà questo robot dalla stazione
come se fosse sulla luna
quindi tele robotica sulla terra
significa telemedicina vuol dire che un
chirurgo a new york può operare un
paziente a milano in più questo braccio
robotico è alla base della
microchirurgia sulla terra ma vogliamo
fare di più vogliamo andare su marte
astronauti su marte entro la fine del
e per far questo avevamo bisogno di
questo
marte è a due anni di distanza da noi
per motivi di astrodinamica noi non
possiamo interrompere la missione quindi
dobbiamo fare tutto il giro
vuol dire che dobbiamo poter riparare
gli astronauti prima pelle primo
assumano stampati 3d con cellule
staminali organi umani vuol dire
possibilità di trapianti senza bisogno
di aspettare un donatore vuol dire
testare le medicine direttamente
sull'organo che si vuole curare senza
far del male agli esseri umani o agli
animali ma perché andare su marte motivo
è questo la terra mantiene le proprie
dimensioni noi continuiamo a crescere
quindi abbiamo un problema di spazi
abbia un problema di risorse
abbiamo un problema di con di
inquinamento quindi andiamo su marte per
aver altri spazi nuove risorse ma non vi
preoccupate non andiamo su marte perché
pensiamo che la terra sia spacciata e
quindi andiamo da un'altra parte no
tutt'altro
noi andiamo su marte per questo motivo
marte era una terra non sappiamo per
quale motivo poi si è trasformato nel
deserto ghiacciato che oggi con effetto
serra completamente fuori controllo
quindi noi andiamo su marte per capire
che cosa è successo lì e per evitare che
succede da noi in più andiamo su marte
con rispetto e in pace
abbiamo un ufficio che si chiama
planetari protection che ci eviterà di
fare gli stessi errori che abbiamo fatto
sulla terra stiamo diventando una specie
multi planetaria
vuol dire che abbiamo l'opportunità per
la prima volta di portare la nostra vita
nostri ideali la nostra cultura su un
altro pianeta
per far questo però abbiamo bisogno di
tutti voi e non saranno solo ingegneri
come me avremmo bisogno di biologi di
medici gli psicologi di filosofi
tutto questo avviene adesso lo spazio
ispirazione quindi noi
attiriamo le menti migliori le
confrontiamo con sfide di questo tipo e
produciamo tecnologia e scienza
protezione della nostra terra e della
nostra vita su di essa ah dimenticavo
tutto questo vi costa come il biglietto
di un cinema all'anno
ora io ho la mia risposta per questa
domanda ed è la risposta che ispira
tutta la mia vita ed ha un senso la mia
esistenza perché penso di fare qualcosa
per quel bambino qualcosa di concreto
lascio naturalmente a voi la libertà di
rispondere grazie
[Applauso]